I'm the unifier original Toronto
Republicans there
obviously the United States of America
and a penny he was not that successful
in breaking the gridlock
if you would have been president how
would you get a United States of America
how to do it what's the trick but first
of all I don't I don't think Washington
is the definition of who we are as a
nation for starters and I think shifting
power away from Washington has to be
part of the solution to this and where
there's much more engagement by people
in having a say in their own lives I
mean you can't outsource this to a never
you know larger and larger government
and expect a good result you have to
assume that the people that disagree
with you aren't motivated that they love
the country the same way I mean I have
deep disagreements with Barack Obama but
I don't think I think he loves the
country and he's just got a different
mindset about how to go about it and I
think he's wrong about that but I don't
I don't ascribe bad motives to make my
point better and as as president you
look at look at Johnson after I've been
criticized by telling the story because
people take it out of context like
somehow I'm a big believer in the
leadership skills of Lyndon Johnson but
when John Kennedy was assassinated in a
six-week period he first got a budget
that was passed that had a year-to-year
decline in it first time since World War
two and he did that by being all in in
dealing with people that were not you
know not from his party as well as
Southern Democrats that controlled the
budget process then he got the the civil
rights bill passed in a six week period
now part of it was that people felt you
know horrible of the assassination of
Kennedy and he got the tax cut the
Kennedy tax cut is really Lyndon
Johnson's doing all of this happened in
a brief period because there was
complete engagement he cajoled he he was
actively engaged he wasn't passive and
removed and he didn't ascribe bad
motives or try to demonize people that
ultimately had to be part of the
solution and he shared the
it this is not the yeah I mean this is
not the most complicated thing in the
world to do today it seems like it's
call most impossible to today but there
are thousands of examples of this
happening in City Council's with mayors
and state legislators with governors and
it and it could happen again in
Washington to assume that it can't
happen that somehow it's impossible for
for the logical way of getting to yes
that we just eliminate that as a
possibility we do it at our peril
I want to pick up though on a point that
you made earlier which is you know in a
way what you say Emma what you just said
about Lyndon Johnson's all true I have a
lot of respect for Lyndon Johnson the
political culture in which he was
dealing however was in a in many
respects an easier one than any
president would have to deal with today
and in part because of certain
Democratic achievements there were with
respect to gender totally different you
know political culture where you know
women did not figure as important people
in American political culture women's
issues did not figure as important
political you know issues in American
culture with respect to race I mean the
fact of the matter is you know that's
right Lyndon Johnson did a lot of good
things but the people who were the
political class at that moment were
virtually all white men it was a far
less variegated diverse and therefore a
far less charged political environment
than we have now so in an ironic way
some of the some of the things that were
moaning about are actually instead of us
viewing them as you know altogether bad
things you know what was spent know in a
large degree they're good things I mean
you know when they're new actors you're
going to have friction you know in the
time that you're talking about in you
know strategic places in American
political culture you didn't have
of Latinos and blacks and women
therefore you didn't have the friction
now you have that presence you have
friction you know frankly it's a good
thing it's going to be tough all I'm
saying is Johnson did he made he got
people to do things that they didn't
expect that there were no that's the
sign of leadership that is the way you
break through to this what what get you
know they yet to be defined system that
we're moving towards that's undefined
yet that looks pretty ugly right now
it's gonna require that kind of catalyst
of public leadership and it exists all
across the country it's just not
existing right now in Washington it's
just not you know it's it's dead
temporarily at least a about how
politics actually works and this is
where the the either wing was the Trump
wing of the Sanders when don't
understand how politics actually works
in Washington could have told the story
of on the team of rivals about how how
the Emancipation Proclamation to help
how Lincoln got things done I mean if
keep on going with that movie and that's
all we can you know every postman was it
all get getting the 30th amendment
through is about politics how politics
operates it involves engagement it
involves understanding where your where
your opponent's weaknesses are but also
not ripping him down but figuring out
how to get it done and this is this is
an art which I think it's been demonized
funnily enough the idea is all you're
just gonna come in there and take over
and make it make it make it happen make
America great again because I can do it
that's not how politics works in this
country never has been and the same on
the left
you know the idea but we're just gonna
do what we're gonna do it we're gonna do
it there are other people out there who
disagree with you you're gonna have to
get something done and you're not gonna
get it done by beating him over the head
you're gonna get good gun bite being a
political leader come back to Randy's
point before cuz I thought it was really
important I mean I think you're
absolutely right that we live in a
changed culture that has many more
voices in it that have to be listened to
and let's say less dogmatic
Partizan consistency and I think one of
the things that we have right now is we
have a national system a political
system that still sees itself as I think
answered this before liberal and
conservative I'm not sure that if you
look at people around the country
they're all liberal were conservative
they have very many different viewpoints
there's a lot of multiple identities
going on in this country many people
have three or four or five or six
identities that they identify with and
um we have created a national political
debate that fits people into categories
left or right could serve at a
Republican Democrat whatever and um one
of the things we may need is to pull
back not simply on money but of a
national conversation and remind
ourselves that you know we may have to
let people in different parts of the
country and in different communities
live differently and um
liberals are gonna have to make more
room for people living in in ways that
they find problematic and conservatives
are going to make more room for people
living in ways that they find
problematic
we're gonna have to listen to each other
and a much more intense way on a local
level than we currently are when there's
this sense that you either have to be
one of these other things and I think I
think the change in who the American
people are is far outstrip to the
political conversation and we need to
pay attention to that